c'est toujours très étrange d'abord à
faire des télécoms sa là je vous parle
de la nouvelle télé auprès d'une des
nouvelles télés de symptômes de cette
année on parle d'un truc qui est juste
énormissime en termes de taille alors il
ya un peu plus petits la blessure de 75
pouces et existe du 65 pouces c'est le
plus petit format il existe du 85 pouces
est ce qui est intéressant ici si vous
voulez c'est qu'on est une télé qui fait
complètement disparaître les bords à
quelque chose près et un truc qui est
assez incroyable et cette télé là elle
coûte un tout petit peu moins mais un
tout petit peu moins de 8000 euros
[Musique]
regardez ça alors déjà la première chose
à voir ici c'est les bords ils sont
quasiment invisibles
regardez c'est juste dingue vous avez
des bords qu'ils sont tout petits qu'on
ne voit quasiment pas lorsqu'on veut un
peu plus ce sont ceux du bas mais
regardez ça c'est tout fin tout petit
alors c'est tout fin mais c'est très
grand on est sur une télé qui est énorme
on est sûr de l'a8 cas ici et en plus si
on regarde ce design parce que je vais
bien aimé c'est qu'on a un pied qui
malgré tout reste quand même très léger
vous pouvez sur la position à pied comme
ça soit carrément venir l'accroché un
mur puisque ça ne s'arrête pas là elle
est extrêmement fine donc si vous venez
la pause et un mur et bien s'attendre à
quasiment pas de place elle juste posé
là sur un tout petit socle et sur ce
socle bien se poser le boîtier
oneconnect dans lequel vous avez les
connectiques ce qui fait que vous avez
juste une connectique derrière votre
téléviseur et tout le reste se situe
directement ici on a du hdmi 2 points en
pagaille
on a également vous voyez ici la deûle
irc on a également de l'usb prise
antenne satellite
on a une sortie optique on a une prise
ethernet et vous avez votre portant
oneconnect qui vient le connecter
directement là et après vous venez
remettre ça très facilement si vous
voulez la fixer au mur vous pouvez les
fixer au mur vous déjà un très grand mur
il faut très grande classe s'offrant une
très grande pièce pour cette année 75
pouces et bien vous prenez ça vous
l'enlever vous avez un plus gros cad qui
est fourni avec vous êtes des portes et
vous la planquer dans un meuble et vous
avez juste un câble parce que le one
connect et bien ça fournit
l'alimentation et toutes les
connectiques à réparer l'hôtesse pro
l'objec tracking sand pro en gros c'est
le son qui vient de tous les côtés du
téléviseur vous êtes donc dans une
immersion complète avec du son qui vient
de tous les côtés de votre téléviseur
alors ici on n'est pas comme chez sony
avec une dalle qui vibre non ici vous
avez des hauts parleurs et vous avez
surtout 80 voix et ses haut parleurs ils
sont planqués la la regarder c'est avec
quatre ici et vous en avez 4 ici autant
vous dire qu'ici au niveau du son il ya
de quoi faire coucou toi coucou toi
soyons clair une télé comme ça c'est pas
fait pour tout le monde c'est pas fait
pour tous les intérieurs moi je ne me
suis en main table de salle à manger
pour quoi et bien tout simplement parce
que j'ai la place uniquement et c'est
déjà très bien pour une télé 55 pouces
une télé 75 coups ça passe pas chez moi
donc quand j'ai vu le carton quand je
les reçois je me suis dit ok ça va être
très compliqué installé on est quand
même en plus sur une télé qui avec le
pied fond
peu plus de 40 kilos il faut les
installer il faut venir la porte est je
vous rassure l'installation c'est quand
même très facilement il faut être deux
et surtout ce qui fait la grande force
de ce téléviseur c'est toutes les
technologies intégrées que vous allez
ici c'est une dalle wicca à 33 millions
de pixels temps vous dire que c'est
quand même relativement énorme
vous vous rendez pas compte mais
derrière là je sens la chaleur qui vient
taper dans mon dos de toute façon c'est
un téléviseur qui nécessite de grands
espaces donc si vous le mettez à
proximité de vous eh bien ça vous
chauffera été comme hiver
vous avez plein de techno à l'intérieur
vous avez la quantum matrix technologie
pro comme vous êtes sûre du mini led
vous avez des lettres qui sont 40 fois
plus petites que des leds standard ça
vous permettra de gérer beaucoup plus
finement les couleurs contraste
luminosité
vous avez derrière le néo quantum
processeur 8 cas avec de l'intelligence
artificielle et 16 réseaux neuraux
clairement j'ai pas la casse à dater
pouvoir réellement en profiter
la poésie dans mon salon et regarder des
heures et des heures de contenu elle est
beaucoup trop grande pour chez moi et
une fois de plus elle dira que pour une
certaine catégorie de personnes qui ont
soit beaucoup de recul soit qu'ils ont
des très grandes pièces et qui dans tous
les cas peuvent être lues 1000 euros sur
une télé on a également la technologie
quantum hdr 4000 avec du hdr 10 plus ce
qui lui permettra d'ajuster scène par
scène élément par élément les couleurs
et les contrastes bien que vous ayez une
télé 8k ya très peu de contenu
aujourd'hui qui sont disponibles en 8k
donc ce que vient faire votre télé ici
et bien c'est faire de l'oeuf skelling
pour monter votre contenu jusqu'à une
qualité 8 k un autre point qui est super
important dans les téléviseurs samsung
et je vous en ai déjà parlé lorsque j'ai
réalisé différents tests et bien c'est
qu'ils ont des supers technologie anti
reflets c'est probablement les
meilleures en tout cas une des
meilleures technologies anti reflet du
marché et il ya un autre point qui est
super intéressant c'est que quel que
soit l'endroit où vous allez vous situez
d'un côté ou de l'autre du téléviseur et
bien vous avez des angles de vues qui
sont très très très bon de tous les
côtés donc que vous soyez sur le côté
puni sur le petit fauteuil de côté ou
alors bien en face et bien dans tous les
cas la qualité préserver et ça s'est
super bien dans cette télé et chez
samsung en règle générale sur les
téléviseurs vous avez plein de
technologies est ici vous avez la techno
qui s'appelle space fit sand qui va
permettre aux sons de programmes toutes
dimensions dans votre pièce en l'ampli
sent un peu de tous les côtés ça n'ira
pas aussi loin que si vous avez des
hauts parleurs dispatcher un peu partout
dans votre pièce mais ça vient malgré
tout apporté une sensation d'immersion
lorsque vous allez me regarder des films
des séries
vous voulez une même joué et même jouer
parce qu'ici un truc est super
intéressant c'est que vous pouvez venir
jouer par an 8 k b évidemment mais jouer
en 4k jouer en 4k à 120 hertz ça vous
apportera plus de fluidité dans toutes
vos parties de gaming et ça c'est aussi
très bien alors oui un autre que j'aime
bien dans cette télé eh bien c'est la
télécommande lé hypra hypra hypra
minimaliste en parle vraiment d'une
petite télécommande on l'a lu ment
l'état peut venir parler à son assistant
vocal ici pour quelques petits réglages
de quoi naviguer ici la maison retour en
arrière montée volumes baisser le volume
on va avoir netflix en avoir prime on va
voir c'est quoi ces samsung + tv et
surtout cette télécommande elle est
vachement intéressante pour un point eh
bien ça vous avez pas être pile à
l'intérieur non il n'y a pas de piles
ici c'est un truc est vraiment différent
un super intéressant ça on pourrait se
dire que c'est petit écran et en fait
non c'est pas un écran 7 un capteur vous
pouvez vient la recharger avec la
lumière de votre intérieur avec la
lumière du soleil
et si vous vivez comme un ermite dans
une maison sans lumière sans rien vous
avez toujours de l'usb ici donc ça
j'aime bien c'est une innovation c'est
intéressant c'est vachement bien parce
qu'on est ici dans l'ultra prémont et
dans de l'ultra haut de gamme ont les
dents du midi les huit cas on est dans
la dernière génération de tellines
samsung 8000 euros une fois de plus la
petite bête derrière donc le fait qu'on
les députés les coquilles sont un peu
différentes jamie alors je regrette un
peu effectivement que voyez on est le
strict nécessaire sur cette télécommande
j'aurais aimé peut-être en avoir un peu
plus qu'il ya l'aspect encore un peu
plus premium
elle est pas mal comme ça il ya ce côté
un peu métal brossé mais en tout cas ce
que j'aime bien ici c'est ça la cette
technologie de charge
c'est l'innovation c'est intéressant ça
apporte en tout cas un vrai plus même si
ça va pas changer grand chose à la face
de votre téléviseur mais quand on est
client et qu'on arrive sur l'innovation
même sur la télécommande comme ça ça
c'est vachement bien
après ici on tourne sous tyson alors
tyson ne sais pas si vous connaissez des
expériences aller vachement bien c'est
l'expérience télé connectée de samsung
bon c'est très standard vous avez accès
à votre console donc si vous avez un
compte samsung ça c'est vachement sympa
puis dans l'écosystème samsung avec
smart cities au milieu bien c'est bien
vous avez les ambiante moi qui serviront
de décoration dans votre intérieur votre
télé ressemblerait à quelque chose près
à une oeuvre d'art elle pour un peu
négatif de 108 mode c'est que même si
c'est sympa et bien ça consomme de
l'énergie
c'est parce qu'elle plus éco-responsable
et ça vous coûte électricité que vous
avez vous différentes applications
applications recommandées y explorer est
venue de huit cas il faut venir
s'abonner ici vous avez également
smartseed pour tout l'écosystème
connectés de samsung contrôlez vos
différents appareils et même votre
domotique
si vous avez un réfrigérateur connecter
via va se connecter vous et pouvoir
piloter depuis votre télé grâce à smart
singh
mal de chassaing pas les différentes
sources effectivement le pc directement
connecté sur la télé et puis vous avez
plein de petits paramètres différents
modes pouvait venir m différents modes
d'image également si vous le souhaitez
vous pouvez venir modifier la luminosité
le contraste la netteté en fonction de
vos goûts en fonction de ce que vous
aimez donc ça c'est plutôt sympa à vous
de voir le son de la même manière en
plis fire ou standard là c'est pareil
vous allez avoir naturel cinéma qui va
devenir un poil plus filmmaker mode
dynamique c'est pas ce luxe préfèrent le
standard je trouve quand même plutôt pas
mal de base
les haut parleurs aussi choisir le son
haut parleur ou par fibre optique comme
vous souhaiteriez pas mal de petits
paramètres
ici il pouvait venir à voir directement
niveau de télé connectée votre réseau
format de l'image les nuances de
couleurs bref ça je vous laisse regarder
si ça vous intéresse mais tel quel et
l'amour natif ça me va bien je trouve ça
c'est intéressant donc ça c'est pour
tous ces réglages là et vous aller bien
plus loin puisque les sur une télé
connectée vous allez service en dessous
vous allez pouvoir avoir netflix si vous
avez un abonnement prennent vidéo disney
c'est exactement la même chose
apple tv rakuten canal de la même
manière youtube pour venir regarder les
différentes vidéos de monsieur gros donc
ça c'est bien et ça marche bien et puis
après vous avez plein d'infos en
fonction des différentes applications
qui sont installés des films installé
voir le monde
bref donc c'est assez intéressant j'aime
bien l'expérience tyson je trouve
vraiment intuitif et pas mal du tout et
vous avez tout un catalogue
d'applications pour venir installer
différentes applications dans différents
univers que ce soit du jeu que ce soit
de la télé que ce soit même de l'audio
du podcast du sport tout ce qui vous
fera plaisir vous l'avez différents
modes de vie aux favoris ya vraiment de
quoi faire c'est une télé pour toute la
famille alors toute la famille très
grande famille avec un très grand écran
une fois de plus lui cas on est sur un
monstre ici mais il ya plein de choses à
faire et moi je me sens vraiment sympa
alors soyons clairs c'est pas une télé
qui est destiné à tout le monde ici ce
qu'on vient voir c'est l'innovation
vient voir un petit peu le futur on se
projette dans le futur sont des choses
qui existent aujourd'hui en 2020 table
et qu'on va pas forcément venir acheter
7990 euros qui va mettre 7 8 990 euros
dans une télé alors peut-être certains
d'entre vous mais moi en tout cas non je
ne mettrai pas 7990 euros dans une télé
mais ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est que au
delà de la télé au delà de de ce superbe
écran au delà de tout ce qu'on peut
faire avec moi ce que j'aime ici c'est
l'innovation que celle innovation signée
samsung c'est cette technologie
l'aide que je trouve super bien et super
intéressante l'idée d'aborder l'aide
beaucoup plus petit ça vous permet
effectivement être beaucoup plus précis
au niveau des couleurs au niveau de la
luminosité au niveau du contraste
l'expérience audio dans cette télé elle
est pas mal
c'est pas le truc qui va nous
transcender le plus c'est pa lo jo le
plus d'un que j'ai pu entendre
par contre ici vous venez la coupler
avec une barre de son est vous aller
beaucoup plus loin a déjà si on est à
quasiment huit mille euros je pense
qu'on peut venir de positionner la
petite barre de son qui va bien pour
rajouter à l'expérience
j'aime bien la télécommande avec le
capteur solaire ça ça me plaît bien
j'adore ça ça chauffe la vache je suis
là je peux vous assurer qu'en hiver
je pose les mains comme ça eh bien j'ai
plus froids comme il faut du recul c'est
pas nécessairement un problème donc ça
j'aime bien vous me dire vous maintenant
ce que vous en pensez comment vous la
trouvez cette télé cette télé
technologie miled qu l'aide qu'est ce
que vous en pensez est ce que ça vous
hype
est ce que ça vous botte est ce que vous
pourriez vous projeter dans les années à
venir
pas forcément tout de suite ou sur cette
technologie que des très grands écrans
comme ça ça vous botte 75 pouces c'est
énorme
il a plus grand encore quand je
transfère 85 pouces je peux même pas
comment j'aurais pu l'installer déjà
celle là sur la table de salle à manger
il fallait le faire donc à vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez bien
évidemment en bas en commentaire comment
vous la trouvez intéressante par
intéressante qu est ce que vous pensez
de toutes ces technologies signé samsung
je pense qu'on reparlera de télé
connectée signé samsung prochainement
parce que il ya plein de choses à
raconter
et moi j'aime bien voilà nouvelles
technos ça me plaît ça m'intéresse à
huit cas ça me botte bien pas pour tout
de suite bientôt les huit cas ça va
arriver les programmes vont arriver les
programmes petit à petit et puis grâce
aux technologies day ce qui est libre on
voit que même si on est en 4k et bien
c'est pas très grave
ça reste quand même bossé reste quand
même le voilà sur ceux des bisous
d'amour et à très bientôt
du tout